思考は怠け勤で完成するという出口がない人生という迷路
はい なんかまだ訳のわからないことがありました
タイムとスペースということ
まあ時間と空間ですね
考えたり計画を立てたりすると
あまり時間と空間の問題を配慮しないのです
もうわかりやすい 読みやすい漢字が出たでしょ
それはそういう意味なんです
よく覚えておいてくださいという
具体的な生き方に関係のない哲学の管轄だと勘違いしている
このタイムとスペースの問題っていうのは
あんなの哲学者が大学の教授が言っているだけで
毎日は関係ないんだと
晩御飯の献立 献立考えるお母さんには関係ないんだろう
よく思っているんです
そうじゃないんです 晩御飯の献立というんですか
献立を考える時もとっても大事なことなんです
歯を磨く時もとても大事なことなんです
これが仏教の立場です
怠けの影響で全て物を通して考える
これちょっと難しいと思います
説明します 後で 我々は怠けだから物で考えるんです A
とかB とかC とかD とか
成功 利益 結果などは停止した物を通して捉えている
我々にとっては世界はモノ
モノ モノ モノ モノ モノ
モノばっかりなんです
時空と関係ないんです
例えばモノといえば 机もモノで
椅子もモノでっていう建物もモノというでしょうね
それだけじゃないんです
成功すると 私は成功しなくちゃ
ということは 自分にとって成功というものがあるんです
あ これ結果出さないと
早くも結果出さないといけないと思うでしょ
その場合は結果があの一つのものなんです
このものっていうのは一般的に時空と関係ないんです
テーブルであればテーブルです
時空関係ない言葉でしょ
ものです 例えば朝ですと言えば時空なんですけど
我々の頭の中で朝という朝という何かなんです
固定概念  え？まあ固定概念じゃないんです
これはもうオブジェクトとして見るっていうことなんです
まあそれではどんどん説明いくんです
手を伸ばしてリンゴを取るというタイトルで始めます
人生はこのようなものだと思って行動するのです
資格を取る 仕事を取る
採算を得る 結婚相手を見つかるなど
全ては取るものになっているのです
で ものでしょ あ 結婚しなくちゃ
じゃあ結婚相手を取らなくちゃ
何がものなんです お金がない
仕事をしなくちゃ では仕事を取らなくちゃ
まあ当然それも固定既定概念なんですけど
この既定概念がものというものなんです
だから なんか人生は手を伸ばしてリンゴを取るという感じで思っているんです
だから このリンゴの例えで考えてください
あの 何かテーブルの上にバケツ
何かバスケットの中にリンゴが入っているかもしれません
あるいは枝に枝にリンゴがあると
それでリンゴがものでしょ
私は欲しいでしょ それで手を伸ばして取る
取ったんです そのように我々は全てのものと考えているんです
気づいてない だから今日の講演で出てくるものはほとんど気づいてないものなんですよ
本当は初めて聞くポイントだと思います
例えばお母さんが自分の子供にものすごくいい小学校に入れたくなっちゃうんです
それもお母さんにとっては何かを取ることなんです
その学校の例で考えてください
子供がいい学校に入れたいという気持ちが良くないんです
それは何か取るということなんです
学校というものがあって
子供というものがあって
そのものはあのものの中に入れるだけの話なんです
正しく考えるならば その子は教育レベルの高いところに入れられるように成長させなきゃいけないんです
そうなってくると うちの子の心の状況は
あの学校のこの学校のあの学校の子供たちとは何の変わりもないんだと
同じか もうちょっと上ばというということだったら
別に自然に学校に入れるでしょうに
しかし 今はいい加減な例なんですけど
その場合もやっぱりものになっちゃいますね
うちの子の能力はといえば
能力という何かものとなっちゃう
だから この皆様もいろんなことをして生きてきたでしょうに
だからいろんなことに挑戦したでしょうに
でも挑戦した割にはそんなに成功したこともないでしょうに
そこでもし過去を振り返ってみることができれば
いつでも何かをものを取ろうとしたんじゃないかな
説明する前にわかりやすくなるではなくて
取ろうなんです 仕事ちょうだいという感じで面接に行くんです
取るために面接に行ったっても
仕事ちょうだいじゃなくて
まあ私にはこういうこういうこういうことができますよ
あんた このうちの会社で仕事するいいですね
あんた方はしなさいと言ったらしますけど
という調子でなければいけません
そんないい加減なやつらと言われたら
違いますよと 自分が馬鹿を見たくないんだと
自分が今までやることをちゃんと成し遂げてきたんだと
だからあなた方はこういう仕事をしますと言ったら
これは見事に成し遂げる自信があるんだ
しかし ちょうだいとは言いません
だからまあ そういう風には誰も言わないでしょうね
随分緊張しちゃって で
質問にもろくに真面目に答えられなくて
どもったりして なんのことなく
淡々と明るくこうやって座って
ああ そうですね これはね
あれやって喋っちゃうと
もう何のことなく あの人みたい
の紙の上に二重まで入ってるんです
だから このなるということで覚えておけばね
人生はなるものであって
取るものではないんです
しかし 我々には人生は取るものなんです
なんで私は取るなるに引っかかっているのかというと
取る場合は時空関係ないんです
なるっていうのは時空の問題なんです
固定して変わらないものとして考えることはすべての問題です
ものをだからものは変わらない
変化しない 固定しているということになって
これ大きな問題なんですよ
もし小学生がなりたい仕事があって
やりたい仕事があって
大学出てからその仕事に就いたらどうなると思いますか？かなり勘違いだと思いますよ
小学生の時考えた世界と大人になってから見る世界って違うんです
だから私は小学生の一年生からこういう仕事をやりたかったんだよと
それだったらかなり頭が悪いんですよ
なる人はいますよ でも頭が悪いんです
じゃあなくて 幼稚園の時は電車の運転士になりたかったと
小学校の時はまあなんだらかんだらになりたかったと
中学校の時はなんとかなんとか別なことを仕事をしたかったと
高校になったところであれこれやりたい
もう大学出たところで
今こういう会社でいいやと決めたというふうなことだったら正しいんです
固定して変わらないものは一つもないのです
ですから 人の思考はすべて間違っているんです
だから このモノをモノモノモノで考えているんだから
まあ固定概念ですけど
概念 概念 概念があって
概念が変わらないし で
そこはレゴの遊びのように組み立てて組み立てていくだけで
ですから 思考はあまり当てにならないんです
時間空間のことを無視しているんです
あ 例えばこういう話を聞いてみてはどうですか？おいしいおにぎりがあります
どう理解する？よく分かったような気がするでしょう
おいしいおにぎりがあります
文章の意味わかる？わからないと思いますよ
でもわかったような気がするんです
それが問題なんです おいしいおにぎりがあるっていうのは間違いなんです
だって時空関係どうするんですかね
だからどこにある？そこをなくてもわかったような気がしたでしょ
だから思考間違ってるんです
おいしいおにぎりがあるってことだけ
あんた何言ってるもんだと反論しないと
場所を言ってないでしょ
位置空間で時間 おにぎりが例えばテーブルの上にあると言っても
おいしい おいしいという形容詞どうします？時間があるんです
おにぎりを作ってから何時間までおいしいということは人間に判断できるのかという
だから おにぎりを作ったお母さんがテーブルの上にそれを置いておいて
例えば８時に作ったならば 12
時までおいしいのおにぎりありますよと
テーブルの上に と言った方がいいんです
それも大ざっぱな言い方ですけど
それで１時になってきて
子供が食べたら これまずい
お母さんって言ったっても知ったもんかと 12
時までですと だから正しく言うならば
例えば８時ぐらいにおにぎり作ったならば 12
時までおいしいおにぎりがテーブルの上にありますと言わなくちゃいけないんです
時空関係ないと言葉には意味がないんです
なのに おいしいおにぎりありますよと言うと
あ そう いきなり だからまあ
そういうことでわかるでしょ
我々はいとも簡単に間違っている
間違っていることに気づくことを気づくことさえもしないという
怠けの誘惑によって何かを取っちゃえば成功だと勘違いする
だから我々は怠けの思考があるんだから
何か取っちゃえば成功
例えば資格取っちゃえばもう大成功
あの大学を卒業すれば大成功
卒業証明書を取っちゃえばいいんです
だから今インターネットでアメリカの大学を卒業したという証明書を取れるんです
勉強する必要ないんです
インドでもできます そんなお金かかりませんよ 5
6万円あれば それってのは
まあもうすごい悪いことだと知ってるでしょうに
まあインド人っていうのは
まあまあ 今現在どうかはわかりませんだけど
前はそんなに経済的に豊かではなかったんだから
やっぱり勉強するんですよ
勉強しても仕事がないんです
だからピーナッツ売ったりなんとかしたりするんです
しかし ちゃんと博士とか取ってるんです
多言語上手で そういう人々は
あっちこっちから大学に入った学生にバイト
パートで論文を書いてあげるんです
だからほんのちょっとおすこなお金をあげたら
まあ頼んだ テーマはこういうこういうって
はい わかりました で  1週間後に来てくださいと
ちゃんと書いてくれたそうです
それは決して悪いものでも否めなものでもないんです
それを出して もう本人は卒業したという
だからまあそういうふうに詐欺師たちが増えちゃうんですよ
大学は詐欺師やってるわけでもないし
あのピーナッツ売ってるおじいちゃんが悪いことやってるわけでもないんです
人がそういう宿題で論文を書いてくれと
もうあんたにはまあ5
6万円あげますよと で
言われたら 私はもうこれが自分にとっていい仕事だからやっちゃっただけの話で
大学を騙す気持ちは全くなかったです
だから誰がそれを誰が犯罪かというと学生なんですよ
なぜそういうことをしたのかというと
取っちゃえば成功というものの思考なんです
でもならないと ちゃんと卒業生になれないと
大学を出ても自分が知識人になれない
迷惑ですよ 社会に 人類に
世界に だから犯罪者たちが科学を学んだりして
で パキスタンとかね で
それであっちこっち原子爆弾を作ることをやら
方法 技術 何でもかんでもソフトウェア
プログラム 何でも売る
そういうすごいことも起きちゃいますよ
だからこの 取っちゃえば成功やとするんですよ
それも怠け思考 大学生が論文を誰かに頼んで書いてもらったら
当たり前怠けでしょ しかし
取っても取れないんです
ものは 金を儲かったら大成功ですかと
それも取る思考でしょ
世間の金を取って取っておいて
いろいろ工夫して それでいっぱい金が貯まる
これ大成功 では 金持ちの家に生まれる赤ちゃんは
その時点で人生は成功しているのでしょうか
もし私が億万長者になったら
私の人生は大成功やとする
いわゆる取ることで成功だとする
そうすると 私に 私の家族に子供が生まれる
私の子供でもある この赤ちゃんが億万長者の家に生まれちゃったんですよ
赤ちゃんも億万長者なんです
ということは 赤ちゃんが人生の大成功者ですかね
それで そんなことはないでしょうね
赤ちゃんも赤ちゃん でも赤ちゃんの周りにはものすごい金がある
金がいくらあっても成功者じゃないんです
幼稚園に行かなくちゃ
小学校に行かなくちゃ
学ばなくちゃ いろんなことがあります
それがなくなっちゃったら
もうあのお金も自分にも何にもならなくなっちゃうんです
目的に行くために自分が車を買って運転する
また そちらに行く人の車に乗せてもらうという選択 2つある
どちらがかっこいい？ある目的に行きたいんです
だから 頑張って自分で車を買って
自分で運転して行く もう一つの選択は
まあそちらに行く 何か乗り物に乗せてもらう
どちらでも結果は同じでしょうに
目的地に行っただけでしょう
だから そのたとえで言いたいのは
取るということは取れないということなんです
金がいっぱい取っても
自分が年取って死ぬでしょうに
じゃあ自分のものじゃないんです
結局は 私の会社だと言っても
会社が大きくなっちゃうと
もう自分のものでないんです
個人的な営業をする会社であっても
やっぱり客がいるし いろいろ契約が成り立っているし
もしかすると一人 二人
三人雇っているかもしれませんし
もう自分ではないんですよ
だからだから何言ってるんです？これ私の会社ですと
あなたのものだったら
あなた好きなようにやってみてください
何もできんで 結局は何もできない
ですから 取っても取れないということはよく覚えておかなきゃいけない
人生は取るものであるならば
野球 野球ボールぐらいのものなら一時的には取れるんです
じゃあ人生は取るものであると
だったら成功というものは
野球ボール程度だったら一応取れますよ
ではキャッチボールを考えてください
キャッチボールやってボール取るでしょ
あれ取れる？なんか取れたような気がするんだけど
取ったらまた投げなくちゃいけないんでしょう
じゃあキャッチボールしようと
一人がボールを投げると
相手が取ってはい出て行ったら
これキャッチボールじゃないでしょうに
はい 取ったと キャッチボールなら取ったら投げなくちゃいけないんです
だから我々人生は取るものだと思っているんだから
取っているのは大体成功しているのはあの野球ボールぐらいのものなんです
大成功はないんです ボウリングのボールを投げられたらどうします？取れる
取れるところじゃないんですけど
怪我するかもしれません
だから人生は取るものだと
成功は取るものだと思っちゃうと
この羽目になるんです
やっと成功したっても
野球ボールぐらいのちっぽけな成功なんです
ボウリングのボールぐらいの成功は取れないんです
だから人間にはなかなか大成功はできないんです
いるんですかね 大成功した人って
どれぐらいよくないんですかね
世の中 野球ボールでも誰かが投げてくれないと取れる
次の問題は 野球 野球ボールを取りたいんだけど
拾ったって面白くないでしょ
店に行って買っても面白くないでしょうに
野球ボール取ったっていうことは
試合であるいはキャッチボールで誰か投げたからなんですよ
その時ですよ 気持ちいいのは
その時でしょ 成功は だからそこで何が読み取れる？成功っていうのはいつでも他人に依存している惨めなものなんです
取る 取る人生なら投げる人も必要になるんです
だから私たちは口を開けて世の中見ているんです
私を成功させてくださいと
惨めです 投げる人の勝手で自分の人生は左右されるんです
だから我々の人生はいつでも世間の勝手で左右されているんです
それは取る人生の惨めな姿なんです
それでもう一つチャプターが終わります